you edge the pool side chlorine stenched
air filling your nose the sound of
splashing and lifeguards whistling
bouncing off the indoor pool facility
walls the water ripples family and
friends egging you to cannonball in the
pool almost beckoning you to jump with
its suggestive waves there remains an
underlying fear one that brings your
hands to your face and causes your teeth
to chatter even as the pool clear as
glass with chlorine hides no secrets a
monster some teeth gnashing megalodon
ascending from the depths of extinction
leviathan curling its barbed tail to
strike its prey at any moment or even
some vast unknowable force ancient as
earth hardly comprehensible to human
minds waiting dreaming to breach the
surface no matter what form this
gargantuan invisible monster takes you
know
one thing once you jump in you will not
return to shore you take a moment
recompose yourself and laugh off the
fear maybe a product of too much
research on the bloop that deep ocean
sound continuing to confound scientists
as to its cause or maybe too much
binging infographics videos on sea
monsters krakens and loch ness monsters
mysterious globsters cast onto shores
throughout america whatever the origin
the thought seems ridiculous to you now
and your fears regarding invisible
sharks stalking the pool perimeter
escape your mind as you hurl yourself
into the water
scp-1128 in the vast archives of a
hidden site stuffed into a drawer
amongst uncountable horrors like it the
scp foundation holds a description of a
vast unfathomable horror that'll make
you more suspicious the next time you
pass a pool lake or even a bathtub or
puddle of water
scp-1128 is a gigantic aquatic monster
lurking in waters unknown and that's all
the foundation will let anyone not
assign to testing know about it while
the foundation has never shed away from
those moby dicks of the deep including
the several thousand kilometer long
arthropod scp-169
and has even utilized such predators in
the past for their own benefit like the
lengthy beast scp-3000
scp-1128 poses a unique challenge anyone
who knows of its description beyond
surface level details will fall under
the anomalies effect the representation
you see now is merely an artist's
interpretation of the basic prompt the
foundation of course had to discover the
monster's effects in the first place the
chain of communication becomes foggy but
a tip from an unknown source alerted the
foundation to the monster's existence
and details regarding its manifestation
one man who had stumbled upon the
entity's full description started
developing acute philosophia the fear of
large bodies of water not bodies in the
water mind you the man refused to relax
on the beach or fly overseas claiming he
could see the monster's dark silhouette
lurking underwater ever scouting for him
this eventually extended to even closed
bodies of water like lakes ponds and
pools still insisting that the creature
swam under the surface trailing him
wherever he went his friends dismissed
him as crazy and he too believed he had
fallen under some hysteria he decided to
take a nice warm bath to soothe his mind
and ease his troubles he turned on the
faucet and let the tub fill up he put on
his best bathing suit ready to calm his
anxiety once and for all this had been
plaguing his mind for far too long and
he was ready to rid all the negativity
surrounding this phobia basically he was
sick and tired of being sick and tired
over the idea of it all he mustered up
the courage and with the anticipation to
just simply relax he took his first
confident step into the tub he paused
for a moment and breathed a sigh of
relief he picked up his other foot and
stepped fully into the bath splash he
fell straight down right through the tub
waves and bubbles blocked his vision his
arms flailed as he sung deeper into an
abyss of water and fear this wasn't
supposed to happen he thought several
moments later while still in a full-on
panic the buoyancy of his body began to
slow his sinking the bubbles from his
underwater screens rose above him and he
began to follow their direction
scrambling back up to where he'd come
just as he made it back to the surface
of the tub water choking and
hyperventilating in terror he swore he
could see a distant creature the very
same that stalked him through oceans and
pools
staring at him shaking he hoisted
himself out of the water and ran out of
the house hysterical he ran through the
surrounding neighborhood desperately
searching for someone he could relay his
experience to blinded by fear he
neglected to spot a puddle in the middle
of the road he ran on he raised his foot
arched forward and landed straight into
the seemingly shallow water splash again
he found himself completely submerged
and drowning after a minute he did
emerge from the puddle but not in one
piece knowledgeable of this incident the
foundation set about expunging any
traces of the monster's description from
the world physical and digital the
description had low distribution
according to the results of foundation
web crawlers but this hardly stopped the
foundation's endeavor with forum posts
deleted individuals located and
anesthetized and catalogs trolled to
ensure the description did not
proliferate the foundation engaged in
what it does best questionably ethical
experiments first they had an anonymous
d-class uninformed of the creature's
effect read the description of the beast
while the pamphlet they gave him
confused him somewhat he didn't feel
particularly frightened by the entity
and he confusedly put on the diving suit
the foundation testers provided him as
they connected him to a cable and told
him to enter a bathtub the d-class did
as they instructed him the d-class
expressed initial confusion at the tub's
depth remarking that it looked so tiny
from the outside as the d-class
continued to descend he analyzed his
surroundings realizing the nautical
reality that enveloped him he asked how
an ocean got stuffed into a bathtub but
the test organizer had no room for
miscellaneous tongue he continued to
descend until he hit the sandy bottom
seaweed covering the ocean floor the
d-class looked around tropical fish swam
in schools coral covered the seabed and
to his right dropped an immense cliff a
sheer edge the test organizer advised
the d-class to approach the cliff and he
begrudgingly complied as he struggled in
his diving suit he fell back and
screamed
scp-1128 the aquatic horror swam
distantly gracefully even and paid no
attention to the d-class so fixated upon
he realized that the creature matched
the one he read on the pamphlet and
almost complained about this when he saw
a blue whale swimming alongside
scp-1128 compared to the monster the
whale looked like a guppy they whale
glided in front of scp-1128's jaws the
monster remained tranquil stared at its
prey and bit the whale in two with one
shot its teeth glistened in the water
the test operator requested the d-class
to pull back and as the cable began to
draw him toward where he came d-class
stared at the creature swallowing the
chunks of whale whole the d-class's eyes
remained fixated on the creature
partially in fright harshly in awe he
wondered how ocean trawlers hadn't
discovered such a giant beast yet but
the world effectively under 100
surveillance something the d-class knew
far too well as a convict yet the
d-class recognized and if not
comprehended partially understood the
ocean's vastness and mystery the dark
depths reveal no inkling as to their
contents and a creature like a giant
squid or the coelacanth can remain in
hiding for centuries if not millennia it
held him in wondrous thought to consider
the vastness of the depths when scp-1128
stopped and stared at the d-class this
feeling of wonder was quickly replaced
with fear as the creature approached the
d-class pleaded with the test operators
for help as the test operators
accelerated the rate of the cable
returning the d-class took short shallow
breaths filling his body with dangerous
nitrogen as he ascended further
impairing his judgment he had devolved
into gibberish and screaming when face
to face the monster consumed its prey
the cable went slack and the test
operator pulled up only a broken wire
snapped the water turning a cloudy red
the test operator knew that the
unprotected d-class had no chance at
survival against the monster but he
could potentially arm and shield them he
had another similarly ignorant d-class
once again dressed in the scuba suit and
entered the tub however the test
operator placed the d-class within a
shark cage a lot of the movie jaws and
lowered the cage in with another cable
and winch system while unsure how this
would fare with scp-1128
the test operator remained hopeful that
the d-class could survive and recount
his story unfortunately as the cage
lowered into the tub the test operator
received no response from the d-class
until the line spontaneously tightened
snapped and loosened hoping to find the
d-class's remains the test operator only
found shredded pieces of metal
torn and twisted like taffy the test
operator decided that he could utilize
the foundation's arsenal to his
advantage and use an anomalously
toughened shark cage in his testing
perhaps using an anomaly like the
clockwork machine scp-914
he gained approval from his higher-ups
to undergo this procedure and after some
testing behind a shining strong as
titanium shark cage which he placed
another d-class within hoping for a
success with the monster however proved
unsatisfactory as the same thing
happened as the previous test only
without any sort of metallic remains
while bitter that the monster had won
again he wondered where the cage had
landed meanwhile foundation forces
labored tirelessly to find scp-1128's
location hoping to avoid any civilian
contact with the creature luckily a gps
signal established itself upon the most
recent d-classes test with the tracking
device on the d-class signifying the
monster's general location the
foundation had redacted the location of
the monster perhaps in a vain attempt to
hide a very near threat from potential
readers the foundation set up a team of
only the most talented boaters in its
forces mobile containment force kappa 12
sea devils upon arriving at the location
the sea devils discovered the previously
enhanced shark cage completely undamaged
however closer inspection revealed
traces of human dna on the bars though
the foundation could not confirm whether
the dna belonged to the previously sent
d-class the test operator while glad his
shark cage survived the monster's attack
still found himself dissatisfied with
the overall results of the test he knew
he needed to quell this creature's
impact before a large population viewed
it or knew of it the horrible beast had
evaded all attempts at peaceful
interaction perhaps with a madness not
unlike captain ahab yearning for the
death of his white whale the test
operator armed a d-class with a
specialized weapon designed to deal with
aquatic threats promptly this weapon
potentially another of the foundation's
precious arsenal could potentially harm
if not kill the creature while he knew
the foundation's mission statement
forbade unnecessary destruction the test
operator felt it may turn necessary if
matters turn any worse thus he sent his
armed d-class through the tub once more
ready to engage the beast in combat the
attempt as one may expect did not last
long the d-class upon spotting the
creature aimed his weapon at the monster
and attacked it but rather than drive
the creature away it only turned
intently upon the d-class as if it
desired a fight the d-class barely
managed to scrape scp-1128
before the creature devoured the d-class
leaving the test operator once again
empty-handed defeated and without any
more resources to deal with the beast
the test operator ceased his attempts at
vesting the creature and followed the
foundation's more cautious approach
expunging any publicly found
descriptions of scp-1128 as needed and
diverting any vessels away from the
anomaly's exclusion zone as maintained
by the sea devils while the creature had
proven treacherous in unexpected
situations prior engulfing the man who
first heard the creature's description
in a rain puddle researchers could
hardly expect what would transpire a
d-class afflicted with the monster's
effect and observed for testing avoided
all bodies of water as required
eventually however the d-class needed to
interact with some kind of water
drinking water in a choice between a
little water exposure or certain death
the d-class felt inclined to choose the
former he filled his cup with water and
for fun placed his finger into the cup
dropping it into the water
scp-1128 unseen from the outside
violently pulled the d-class through the
cup into its watery domain the d-class
had not a chance to screen this alarmed
containment staff now cognizant that
even the tiniest specks of water could
transport an afflicted person into
scp-1128's ocean territory this proved
particularly strenuous when a new report
of a potential scp-1128 manifestation
arose an old woman isolated with her
cats and knitting supplies found an
article online with a description of the
monster frightened and disgusted by what
she read she closed the article and
continued on with her monotonous life
such a life would take a turn for the
worse however when she too developed
that all-encompassing water-based fear
her apartment overlooked an outdoor pool
and one day looking outside she swore
she could see that same dark silhouette
as the man did lurking in the water
among kids and parents playing she
swiftly closed the window curtains and
taped the seams shut allowing no light
to peek through eventually this paranoia
affected her hygiene neglecting showers
and baths for fear of the creature's
wrath she swore she could see the
silhouette in any individual droplet of
water her skin began to flake as she
avoided water as much as humanly
possible cracks developing on her arms
legs and face inflaming into rashes and
itches her scratching further increased
the flaking she even eliminated water
from her diet sealing the faucets with
duct tape and consuming exclusively
orange juice she threw out her cat's
water bowls dehydrating them they
pleaded with her as she continued to
devolve avoiding any contact with the
outside world even as it attempted to
contact her eventually a concerned
neighbor contacted the local police
concerning the situation and the case
caught the foundation's radar
recognizing the symptoms of a potential
scp-1128 infection a mobile task force
disguised themselves as civilians to
enter the apartment building and
potentially interfere with the woman's
condition they entered the complex
climbing up the stairs with barraging
equipment for forced entry as would
prove necessary to use to enter the
woman's apartment she had nailed the
door shut with wood and sealed the
cracks along the sides with plaster in
an attempt to keep out any water vapor
she had similarly blocked the window
with wood planks a horrid miasma of dead
skin and citrus filled the apartment the
old woman soaking it in ever avoiding
the dreaded monster the foundation task
force attempted peaceful entry knocking
on the door and asking if anyone lived
in the apartment the woman couldn't
speak if she wanted to her throat had
dried to near silence save a croak
suddenly the task force and the woman
heard a rumbling noise outside thunder
rain
the woman panicked and yelled don't come
in here in a froggy voice the task force
eventually decided they needed to use
their equipment and entered via barrage
the door collapsed and an immediate
dense air clogged the task force's sight
blinding and choking them the woman
shrieked and backed against the window
inadvertently the task force insisted
they were here to help the woman but she
simply heaved heavily saying something
unintelligible in that dry cracking
voice the rain began pounding on the
window hatter powder powder as the task
force attempted to gain hold of the
woman she resisted their movements
moving around the room while the task
force intentionally avoided violent
confrontation the rain grew in its
intensity as the woman continued running
around her apartment tripping over her
starved cats eventually she fell back
onto the window at which the boards
blocking it fell onto the floor exposing
the pouring rain fully she screamed as
she saw the silhouette of the monster
staring at her in every individual
raindrop one drop landed on her skin and
she violently vanished pulled into a
minuscule speck of water the task force
collapsed from exhaustion perhaps
dreading their inevitable amnestic
treatment following exposure with an
scp-1128 afflictee yet they couldn't
help but wonder what the old woman saw
in a single speck of water that could
cause that degree of fear and paranoia
the kind of fear only caused by entire
oceans condensed into a single droplet
besides the monster what else did she
see in those multitude of droplets the
fish that populated the sea the whale
carcasses left behind by scp-1128 the
sea devil's viewed from below drifting
on the water unsuspecting just as one
may view a grain of sand and see the
sahara she too saw that raindrop and
viewed an ocean entire along with
whatever malevolent creatures inhabit it
one may have more sympathy for the child
reluctant to jump into the pool water
knowing not necessarily that something
inhabits that body of water but that the
body belongs to a cycle much larger than
itself larger than any sea or ocean and
the only thing that can traverse that
cycle is a monster a creature like
scp-1120
the task force went back to their local
site to report what happened during the
incident like so many incidents the
foundation deals with the sum total of
those that risk their lives for the
greater good is a couple memory erasing
syringes and another update to
documentation a description of scp-1128
remains in the stuffy locker lurking in
weight among other horrifying stories in
the scp databases sea of terror just
like that test operator that attempted
to best the monster could the
foundation's attempts ever surmount the
possibility of another person being
afflicted could they conquer the sea in
a member of that task force's dreams
they perceive a dark blue ocean and the
distant black shadow that resides within
and from this ocean they can view the
bathtubs sinks pools puddles cups of
water and rain droplets of the world
seen from below although they know not
what scp-1128 looks like they too
experience the fear it summons among
those that do the paranoia the fear
although it may not manifest directly in
people's lives it can always be observed
stalking
waiting
lurking under a murky surface
watching with hidden eyes now go check
out scp-3000 anita shisha and
scp-057-it under the sea for more
anomalous entities that lurk in the deep
and dark depths of the sea